well we celebrated last night really my
wife and I and my eldest grandson were
watching the program and you know just
like Glenn Hoddle and Gary Lineker
jumping out of their seats is exactly
what we did it was a replication of that
it was just an amazing moment now at one
stage during the match we're of course
talking were battling this three gold
deficit you tweeted to say oh well I can
cancel my flight to Madrid of course
where the finals taking place I know
you're right absolutely right absolutely
right so I I had luckily lucky it was my
own plane because I had and the bloke I
sent a message to saying that we'll hang
on a minute don't be so pessimistic and
of course you were too pessimistic did
you think that you had enough faith in
your team well look you know we'd seen
Liverpool the night before we talked
about the spirit of Liverpool which was
fantastic and we was hoping that our
boys would show the same the same the
same spirit in the first half it didn't
look too good did it so anybody with the
right mind would think well they've
scored two goals and we're already one
down so we're now got to score three so
there you go don't look like I'm going
to Madrid I said why are you going to be
going to Madrid definitely going to
Madrid and I've also asked him this chap
here what he thinks of the result last
night he's not very happy about it he
says on your your team Arsenal tonight
they're playing in the ladies
tiddlywinks link linked and I aren't
they know it doesn't want to talk is is
his uncharacteristic of him he's just
not ready to talk with me to talk to me
at the moment it's a shame about you
know us ending up above you this year
and also you not being in the Champions
League don't you think it doesn't want
to talk to me it's very uncharacteristic
of the chap don't you think
and Piers Morgan and who the hairdryer
is depicting big arsenalfan Tottenham's
rifles
my understanding is you've had a bit of
a bet with him as well can you just tell
us what that's about
well me and him we've had a bet that
Spurs is going to win the Champions
League and he's going to pay ten
thousand pounds to Great Ormond Street
Hospital right he's copped a Defen again
what do you think it says about the
state of English football and the
Premier League that you've got Liverpool
and Tottenham both in the Champions
League final after these incredible
games of football that we've seen this
week I must show the quality of the of
the football in in England I mean it's
obviously the highest highest quality
we've got the highest quality players
around companies like your good self pay
a hell of a lot of money for the
television rights and consequently that
money is invested in the best players in
the world when you've got the best
players in the world playing in England
it's inevitable that eventually we're
going to have the best football here and
it's very interesting and in all
seriousness the other league that's
being played tonight we could end up
with Chelsea playing Arsenal so there
you've got four kind of tournament four
clubs in the two big top tournaments
European tournaments